man evolved in the universe relatively
recently in comparison to the age of our
planet earth
throughout its existence our earth has
experienced a great number of natural
disasters which noticeably affected the
way it looks today
however it is the info of meteorites
that can be singled out as the cause of
the most dramatic
changes and the number of these bodies
that have hit the planet's surface
is quite uncountable imagine finding out
that a giant asteroid was on a collision
course with our planet
what consequences do you think this
would lead to and what about the place
where the largest ever meteorites struck
the earth
what does this place look like today
cosmo the first in outer space
first of all let's dwell upon the terms
used in science to refer to such
astronomical bodies
the term asteroid was coined at the
beginning of the 19th century
it was used to refer to star-like dots
that can be seen through a telescope
and which differed from planets by their
appearance of disks
that was the reason why asteroids used
to be classified in the same category as
small planets
up until 2006 the defining parameter
being their diameter
that had to measure not less than 30
meters celestial objects falling short
of this size are called meteoroids
astronomical bodies that eventually burn
up in our atmosphere fall into the
category of meteors
and those bodies that make it to the
surface of our earth or any other large
object in space are referred to as
meteorites
on impact most of them have a mass
ranging from several grams to dozens of
tons
on average the overall mass of
meteorites falling on the surface of our
planet every year
may reach as much as approximately 2 000
tons
generally meteorites enter the earth's
atmosphere at speeds of approximately 50
kilometers per second
as a result of such rapid movement we're
able to observe heated fireballs of
intense brightness
on reaching the surface of a planet a
meteorite would have experienced heating
and ablation on its way
and its mass would have become smaller
than what it was on atmospheric
entry as for tiny celestial bodies with
no mass to speak of
they burn up almost completely after
experiencing speeds of over 25
kilometers per second
when a meteorite makes it through the
earth's atmosphere it loses its forward
velocity as it decelerates due to air
drag
this in its turn subsequently changes
the trajectory of the fall
for example if the original trajectory
of the meteorite's fall is horizontal
as a result of deceleration on its way
it may drop towards the surface of a
planet
almost vertically simultaneously the
fireball gets dimmer during the process
and the object itself considerably cools
down
but if an astronomical body manages to
reach the surface of the earth in the
end
it collides with it and this phenomenon
is known as an impact event
as a rule a crater is usually formed
upon impact
and there is a risk of a fire an
earthquake or a tsunami in the area
an impact event is able to trigger some
really disastrous processes
some theories have it that it is
meteorite sinful that is to blame for
major extinction events of species in
the past
when an astronomical object of this kind
collides with the surface of our planet
at high velocity
a staggering amount of energy is
released accompanied by powerful
explosion processes resulting in the
formation of a crater
with a diameter by far larger than that
of the meteorite itself
for example the well-known crater in
arizona with a diameter of 1.2
kilometers was formed about 50 000 years
ago
when the surface was hit by a 50 meter
astronomical body with a mass of
approximately 300
000 tons the force of the explosion upon
impact was comparable to the explosion
of 8 000 atomic bombs of the kind
dropped on hiroshima
following an impact event there may
appear rock formations as a result of a
process known as shock metamorphism
as some mineral deposits like copper and
nickel deposits in the sudbury basin
have come to be
thanks to this phenomenon meteorite
craters may measure up to 500 kilometers
there may even be settlements within
their borders
for example the red fort crater located
in south africa
was dubbed after the town inside it with
the crater's diameter reaching 300
kilometers
just to compare it has about 1.3 of the
cheek shaloob crater
or the sudbury basin the object was
formed over 2 billion years ago as a
result of the earth getting hit by an
asteroid with a diameter measuring
approximately 10 kilometers
vredefort is considered to hold the
second place among the most ancient
craters on earth
and is beaten only by suaviary whose age
is about 2.4 billion years
and which is thus several hundred
million years older
the object is also the largest crater
apart from the unexplored wilkes land
crater
with a diameter of approximately 500
kilometers covered by an ice shield in
antarctica
the wilkes-land crater is likely to have
been formed on a collision with an
asteroid
whose diameter measured about 60
kilometers
at first scientists were unable to
determine the date of its formation
but recent studies revealed that the
crater's age is approximately 250
million years
it is highly likely that this impact
event caused the mass extinction in the
permian period
it would have been dramatic to such a
point that 96 percent of all
ocean species and 73 of all land species
died out as a result of this collision
however to date this version has not
been confirmed as exploration of the
crater is difficult
due to its location it is worth
mentioning
that not all meteorites leave giant
craters upon impact
and many astronomical bodies hit our
earth with by far less force
the hoba meteorite for instance didn't
leave any large crater
but it is this object that is the
largest astronomical body
ever to have been found on the surface
of our planet
this object is the biggest piece of iron
of natural origin
on earth as for its mass it is estimated
at 66
tons the meteorite's volume is 9 cubic
meters and its diameter measures about 3
meters
hoba hit the earth approximately 80 000
years ago
although his discovery was made only as
late as in 1920
near the town of grotfontain which is
situated in the republic of namibia
in africa it was a chance discovery
as neither a crater nor any other signs
of the four were to be seen that would
be indicative of the impact
a possible reason for this could have
been hobes deceleration in the
atmosphere
[Music]
the object's surface is smooth and flat
which is untypical of most meteorites
as for its chemical composition hobe is
a dense metal object with 84 percent of
iron
16 of nickel and also traces of cobalt
even though the meteorite has never been
weighed its original mass is estimated
to have been approximately 90 tons
interestingly the hoba meteorite didn't
cause much damage to the planet's
surface which is really stupefying
as a rule the gravity of consequences
depends directly on where such an object
falls
for example the meteorite whose force
supposedly caused the extinction of
dinosaurs
fell in the vicinity of the yucatan
peninsula hitting shallow waters in an
area where there were gypsum or plaster
rock deposits at the time
as a result large amounts of sulfates
were released in the atmosphere
which in its stern led to the prolonged
period of global winter
since the asteroids struck the earth at
an angle of about 60 degrees
a great amount of dust was released into
the atmosphere
as for the collision itself it would
have caused its tsunami of about 80
meters
a high temperature shock wave would have
swept across the entire planet's surface
causing wildfires on its way and
particles of dust and suit floating in
the air
triggered a climate change when direct
sun rays rebounded from the dust cloud
not reaching the surface of the planet
this cloud would have persisted for
several years
it goes without saying that the chance
of a collision of the kind taking place
today
is infinitely small as the fall of a
large meteorite is a rare occasion
however man hasn't yet come up with a
contingency plan to ensure our safety
should a threat of this kind actually
materialize
just to give an example one of the most
dangerous asteroids on a collision
course with our earth
is 1950 d a a small near-earth object
with the highest palermo rating of the
potential hazard of impact
the closest approach with the asteroid
is going to take place in 2032
and the odds of its hitting the earth in
the year 2880 are estimated at 1 in 300
at the most
in this case the human race is going to
be affected by catastrophic calamities
such as a global climate change with a
significant part of the biosphere
getting destroyed
as a result the diameter of 1950 d
a is 1.3 kilometers and its mass hasn't
been estimated yet
the second most potentially dangerous
celestial traveler is considered to be
the banu asteroid
which is estimated to be just 300 000
kilometers away from our planet
in the year 2135 the date of its
possible info
fluctuates between the years 2175 and
as this is the period when the banu
asteroid will approach the earth
relatively closely on 78 occasions
but the odds of it hitting us are one in
four thousand
[Music]
the asteroids average diameter measures
over 510 meters
and its mass is estimated to be between
60 and 78 million tons
a collision of an object like that with
the earth is tantamount to the explosion
of a bomb of 1150 megatons
in tnt equivalent just to compare
the most powerful bomb ever tested by
humans on earth
was the tsar bomber with a power of
about 58 megatons in tnt equivalent
it is quite likely that science will
soon find a way of changing trajectories
of potentially dangerous astronomical
objects heading towards us from the
infinite depths of outer space
but before it is made possible we can
only hope that no impact event of such
devastating force
will take place on our earth for at
least the next thousand years
[Music]
you